all right we have a quorum
thank you representative Bean for coming
from your sick bit
he wishes to remain isolated and so we
respect him
we're now back in in finance committee
back in session
with the approval of the work we've done
the last few months few weeks
um it will it will include approving the
amendment to hb1a and hb2a
so
I move to accept Amendment one two four
four h for Amendment one hb1a seconded
by second
Mr charges have a procedural question
over here
since this representative thank you I'm
sorry
um since this is an amendment are we
voting for the amendment and then ought
to pass as amended or are we so there's
two votes coming or is there just one
vote and this is the accepted package
there are two votes coming thank you
correct we'll first vote
roll call on the amendment then ought to
pass as amended
uh
representative lieschman have a question
I'll speak after we vote in the
amendment when we vote on the finals
okay
because we will have another opportunity
then
further discussion from committee
members push your button so I can see
the red light if you wish to speak
all right seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the acceptance of
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes
representative uh
representative Sweeney yes
yes representative Wallner
representative Auburn no
Rosanna leishman yes
Arizona buco
no
oh representative
grassy
no
representative Hewitt no
representative Murray
no
representative Heath
no Representative no
original hake and Phillips no
and representative Wilder
yes
Mr chair of the vote is 15 to 10 in
favor of the motion
the amendment is adopted
now Wyler and Earth move
Amendment or move hb1a ought to pass as
amended by Amendment one two four four
[Music]
comments from committee representative
leishman
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to be
voting yes on this bill as amended I
think you probably may recall my
speaking on it when it was before us
before
I can't abandon the work that one
division one is done especially for
issues like retirement colas
food waste uh
elderly services for fraud at the
justice department areas that we added
such as taking away
oplc we were overwhelmed with the amount
of activity or necessary work that that
would have required we remove that from
the governor's budget there are things
not only in division one but I looked at
division three and an issue I know
important to all of us is the DD
Community language is put in there so
there will never be a DD waiting list if
money is necessary to continue they can
come to the fiscal committee these are
all very important things and most
especially again to highlight the pay
raise that our state employs over 9 000
will be getting with our positive
actions today it's a hundred million
dollars in each year it covers everybody
with a 10 and 2 percent raise for the
following year so a 12 percent raise for
our state employees I would encourage
everyone knowing that this is going to
the second or third base when it gets to
the Senate I want to thank my Republican
colleagues for allowing me to
participate in negotiations to try to
I know that the Democratic leader is
still looking at the proposal that was
offered which I thought was a a very
good one personally and I'll speak just
briefly to that so you also know where
I'm coming from the Republicans were
willing to give up the entire rainy day
fund to help satisfy the needs of our
caucus the Democrats so fill in some of
those holes so again I appreciate you
listening to me and I thank the chair
for his Indulgence
thank you
further discussion from committee
members representative Walnut yes thank
you Mr chair
so I am going to be voting no and as
representative leishman just um
stated
we have been in negotiations around the
budget
I I hope that we are making some some
movement and I know that the Democrats
are here and willing to continue working
I don't think that we're there yet
there's still a number of areas that we
have
um
some pretty strong differences
and I'm hoping that in the next few days
before next Thursday we can come to some
sort of um
some sort of an agreement but for the
present time I am going to vote no
um there's a number of
things that I feel like
we did not complete in this budget even
though we did have the ability to do it
but we were not able to
finalize a number of areas so I will be
voting no thank you
representative McGuire
well as you can guess I have a question
um
is what representative leishman said
those was somewhat surprising to me and
I'm going to assume that what he meant
when he said give up the entire rainy
day fund he didn't mean the balance he
mean the additions the 44 million thank
he meant the part that was going to come
into it as a result of this present
representative is that nordgren
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to know
if representative Leachman I think he
misspoke I think he talked about the
fiscal committee being able to allocate
yes you know my recollection looking at
your Division III action it said that
additional funds I'll look at the sheet
but it said that they could come to the
fiscal committee
and representative sitting to my right
Earth agrees with that
yes that's what we did in the fiscal
committee
um to make sure that the money is that
we
extracted from the FY 23 Surplus well
Surplus is the wrong word but um not
Appropriations forward for the DD
would be substituted for if need be and
then beyond if need be go to the fiscal
committee
there were several areas that
traditionally always come to the fiscal
committee the um
attorney general and the
judicial Council
when they need extra money we we never
know what they'll need so we kind of
leave it open and and assume we'll have
a few
dollars left when we when they come to
the fiscal committee because it's hard
to predict what they'll need
this is for the record Mr chairman if I
could member's interest it's page three
uh items 33 a row 33 35 and 37. on the
Surplus statement
the detail change station detail change
state
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended for
hb1a amended by
amendment number one two four four
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes president McGuire yes representative
Petri votes yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes
representative set yes representative
Sweeney yes original Campbells yes
representative popovichi mower yes
Representative walner no Representative
nordgren no
no represent a leishman yes
representative Buco no
representative grassy no
representative Hewitt
um
representative Heath no
representative Murray no
representative evil no no there's no
worski no representative haken Phillips
no
representative Stringham no
Arizona Wilder
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 14 to 11 in
favor
thank you hb1 has been adopted as
amended we'll now move on to Minority
Report probably
we'll write The Minority Report yes
there is a Minority Report
representative Walnut will write The
moving on to hb2
the amendment before us is one two four
seven
Weiler moves Earth seconds that
Amendment one two four seven to hb2 be
adopted
further discussion on hb2 Amendment one
two four seven over here
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair there are a couple things I'd like
to say about hb2
um it didn't get much fanfare last
budget when we did this but we offer uh
true and direct
property tax relief at the county level
in hb2 by uh increasing or having a
relatively high level of
State money being invested in
maintaining a a lower County cap for our
nursing homes in Rockingham County that
calculation was seven percentage points
uh in the in the previous or in the
current year so so we offer uh exactly
what we hear from our taxpayers they
need property tax relief we delivered
that in hb2 the other thing I'd like to
do is to say uh probably for the third
time in a hearing that I I think that we
did some really great work that we
should be proud of even as we continue
to negotiate with one another but there
ought to be a recognition I think that
the governor had
um
not proposed a Medicaid reimbursement
hike that would be targeted he offered a
3.1 percent increase and the and
encouraged us to find a way forward and
uh and so without much guidance we got
together we encouraged Community
involvement the community came forward
and gave a recommendation that turned
into representative Stringham putting
together a proposal as the Republicans
did one in parallel we accommodated each
other in terms of what eight the rhb2
item would look like it's really nice
algorithm so that whatever amount of
money we can invest the the math sort of
take care of care of itself and it
provides a tremendous amount of relief
if we can get it passed so I would ask
you to get this passed because if we
can't pass hb2 at the end of the day all
that great work on increase seeing
Medicaid reimbursement on a targeted
basis goes away and I think that would
be very destructive of our Health Care
system so I'm going to vote Yes on hp2
and would encourage my colleagues to do
and I would I would remind everyone that
the constitution says the New Hampshire
house
does the budget
the governor can provide input but it is
not a budget until it is passed by the
legislature
so
we also had 50 bills that our colleagues
passed through the house
that were largely included in hb2 and
hb1 so
that almost added 300 million dollars so
yes we're spending more than the
governor but there were legislative
Imports that came later so those had to
be accommodated and we've had to do
quite a bit of moving around the pieces
it has been a difficult task and I
appreciate all the efforts uh
representative leishman you want to talk
now or later about all the work you did
on hb2 well it's all the work my
committee or division did the credit
goes to them Mr chairman
thank you any further discussion on
the amendment
1247h to hb2
seeing none the clerk will call a role
on the motion of adopting the amendment
one two four seven
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
set yes representative Sweeney yes
Arizona cambrose yes representative
Mueller yes Representative walner no
Representative nordgren no
yes
there's an abuco no
representative grassy
no
representative Hewitt no
representative Heath
no
president Murray no representative evil
Rosanna tolorski no there's no haken
Phillips no
and representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 15 to 10 in
we have adopted amendment 1247h to hb2
I now move and represent Earth's seconds
that we adopt
the motion ought to pass as amended for
hb2 with Amendment 1247h discussion from
the committee members representative
Stringham
um you know I'd like to
um uh second that my colleague's
comments on about the really good work
supporting the counties uh uh uh groups
like the community health centers many
of the other waiver programs there was a
lot of substantial progress made uh in a
in a very short period of time and great
cooperation I think on both sides I am
still going to vote against this hb2 at
this point mainly because there's some
unresolved issues that I think we can
make make progress on and that are very
very important for the state and for the
long-term future this of the state
including education funding formulas
some tax related issues and boosting the
Medicaid rates enough uh to actually
keep keep them from collapsing but that
doesn't diminish what we've done to
reduce the emergency room and parking
problem and I think we can be very proud
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman I'm looking forward to voting
yes on hb2 as amended I was proud to
vote for hb1 it is a bipartisan budget
that we have built over the last few
weeks and months in the state of New
Hampshire we are increasing spending
nearly a billion dollars without
increasing a single tax or fee as a
testament to the strength of our Granite
State economy and I'm proud of that
recognition of fact that we don't have
to increase taxes or fees to make sure
we are meeting the needs of the people
of our state there's always going to be
parts of a budget we don't like that is
just the basic bare minimum fact of
reality that there will be parts of a
budget you may not appreciate you may
not like what we've been hearing is it
doesn't spend enough we are spending
over roughly billion dollars more than
the last biennium without increasing
taxes without increasing fees we should
be proud of that it is a strong
bipartisan budget today that delivers
for the people of New Hampshire to
delivers for police officers and
firefighters who were joined the service
before 2011 in restoring that retirement
promise to them it delivers for the the
providers in Medicaid reimbursement
rates and we're not in disagreement that
we want to increase those further but we
we have to find the money to do so with
our constraints it is a good budget it
is a bipartisan budget there's a lot of
pieces in the budget I'm not a fan of
I'm voting for it because it is good
policy for the State of New Hampshire
for the next two years I know we could
all go around the room point out the
pieces that we hate in this budget but
there is a lot for everyone to love and
that's why I'm voting for it I urge my
colleagues to recognize that fact that a
lot of the positions the house has taken
that may differ with other people in
this building or across the street those
will be gone if we do not pass a budget
that is what we're playing with here if
we say oh it's it's not what I want
exactly then we are throwing out we are
letting perfect be the enemy of the good
and that is bad public policy it's bad
way to budget and I would just urge
everyone to vote yes thank you
further comments from committee members
representative Wallner thank you
Mr chairman
so I am going to vote no but like I said
before I think
um we have been spending some time in
the last couple of days trying to come
to
some agreement on some of the issues
that
have divided us and
um there are many things in this budget
that we should be very proud of and the
governor sent us a budget that gave a 10
and a two percent rate increase wage
increase to our state employees
we're all know how desperately that is
needed and how much in support we are of
that
um it also went a long way in fixing a
problem for some of our retirees that
happened a number of years ago
so there are there are lots of good
things here we've taken a big step
towards trying to address the Medicaid
Rate rates paid to our Vital providers
it has not gone far enough I think we
need to continue to look at that that's
one piece of what is not really going to
meet the needs of the providers and
these are providers that we our state
needs desperately without them expenses
will be much much higher
um in the budget I think there is
something that feels to me like it is
really
does not need to be here at all and that
is
um Medicaid expansion the Senate has
sent us is sending us a bill they have
passed it they're sending us a bill
actually someone told me that the public
hearing is next Wednesday on that bill
um that is the time for the house to
weigh in
not in the budget
so that piece being in the budget I
think is is a problem for many of us
um
hopefully within the next week we can
work out some of these differences and
on next Thursday hopefully we'll see a
different a different outcome but today
I am going to vote no on this on House
Bill 2 as amended
seeing none the court the clerk will
call the roll on ought to pass as
amended hb2 as amended by amendment
number one two four seven
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
set
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative um kimberles yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Walder no
Representative norgren no
president Leachman
Arizona buco
no
where's an aggressi no representative
Hewitt no
version of Heath no there's a Murray no
representative evil no
no it was in tolorski no representative
haken Phillips no representative
Stringham no representative Weiler
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 14 to 11 in
okay
Mr Kane is there any further action we
need to do to have you
we will stand in recess and we will have
some take thanks to those of you that
voted at the community college
luncheon yesterday for their culinary
arts we'll bring the cake down and we'll
all have some cake thank you very much
we are in re we are
we're not in recess
and representative Walden will you also
write The Minority Report on hb2 thank
okay
morning